[Music]
you have a big title fight coming up now
a lot of boxers have male athletes say
that it's a superstition don't have sex
before no sexual activity before a fight
and and I'm just curious is that a
superstition that women have in boxing
it's actually it's the opposite for
women if you have sex that raises your
testosterone so it kind of sucks that
I'm a boyfriend right now but I'm sure
my Twitter's blowing up right those
offers at the moment but yeah it looks
like we're taking it out of them or
something I don't know the exact science
behind it maybe a pick-up line or
something I heard before who knows Juno
the science behind it you really believe
that were you to get it on with it would
actually well come on that's what people
said in the 70s that it would that it
would help you before a fight well at
least would help your confidence I think
yeah okay
all right you are gonna have you should
check your Twitter site cuz you got a
lot of people watching my other like I
will help you
[Laughter]